la question tu me vous ici quand vous
allez à gauche quel âge en moyenne 11
personnes le fameux entretiens de stage
aux dents bouche quelques minutes à
peine pour convaincre
pour chacun de ces jeunes tenue attitude
élocution peuvent décider d'une carrière
à compétence égale bien des détails vont
ouvrir ou fermer des portes
moi ça me jurez que mon cabinet
quelqu'un vienne vous avez quelqu'un
l'accueil qui vous avait 3 qui va
jusqu'au cou moi je ne le supporte n'est
pas parce que c'est l'image de mon
entreprise que vous pouvez lire vous
êtes une ambassade dans une entreprise
n'oublie pas ça depuis 2010 chaque
rentrée sur le campus est l'occasion de
mieux préparer les jeunes dans leurs
démarches auprès des entreprises on est
un petit peu stressé donc on va bien
payé mais en fait tout est dans le fait
d'être à l'aise avec le professionnel si
nous met à l'aise on sera à l'aise et on
pourra tout de même se vanter et pouvoir
réussi notre notre ans prochain est-ce
que c'est vécu comme une épreuve
l'entretien pas vraiment plutôt moi je
dirais plutôt mettre un visage sur la cv
et un bon visage en fait montrer qui on
est ce à défendre en fait ce fut un
petit pitch rapide pour l'intrigué on
est donc je trouve que c'est assez
intéressant il faut se tenir
correctement pour effet de faire bonne
impression
à l'embouchure vraiment moche ou est ce
que pour un entretien
tu un soin particulier à te dire bon je
vais peut-être pas garder mes boucles
d'oreilles ou est-ce que tu assumes
complètement ta coiffure des boucles
d'oreilles la coiffe 0e et les boucles
d'oreilles g8
c'est un petit sacrifice que tu fais oui
c'est un sacré bonne cause savoir se
vendre
ça prend avec la pratique mais attention
seuls launay teppei face à une
entreprise
j'ai eu un jour un candidat qui
prétendait parlez l'anglais couramment
son cv et lorsqu'on a commencé à parler
en anglais vraiment assez assez basique
coin non pas des choses extrêmement
sophistiqués je me suis rendu compte
qu'il ne parlait pas un mot d'anglais et
son excuse et rbc ouais c'est ma copine
qui a préparé mon cv je savais pas qu'il
avait mieux que je parlais anglais
couramment quoi oui c'était de choses en
inutile de dire qu'on n'a pas poursuivi
ce matin près de 80 entreprises viennent
rencontrer les étudiants parler de leur
métier répondre aux questions et souvent
échanger leurs cartes de visite pour un
stage ou un emploi futur
chaque année la compagnie air france
fait partie de celles qui recrutent
nous avons 230 points que nous offrons
de bac à bac plus cinq comme je vous
disais en cinq familles de métiers
je pense qu'elle a lu devant les trouver
leur compte c'est un recherche de s'agir
également de sa gérante tout à fait
chaque année non seulement plus d'une
centaine de stagiaires en ce début
d'année le forum donne donc un message
positif aux étudiants il y a des
perspectives pour eux avec ce conseil
motivation et détermination feront toute
la différence devant un recruteur